hi everyone cool okay yeah that is as
bright as it was in the other room I'm
and I cannot see any of you and your
expressions except for like the first
row I'm so yeah good afternoon thank you
so much free yeah coming here and
enjoying me this afternoon
and thank you so much for it FITC for
bringing me to talk to like it's a
really beautiful city so thank you so
much my name is Shirley and I'm an
independent creator of data
visualizations I started out my career
back in 2012 as a software engineer on a
big data company and that's also where I
first learned d3.js and how to create
data visualizations on the web and I
loved that so much that in 2014 I ended
up taking my second role as a front-end
developer for a data visualization
product and in 2016 I decided to quit my
full-time job and go all in and take the
leap and start doing freelance
specifically for data visualization
projects on the web and then the last
three years I've had the incredible
pleasure of working with different
clients across a variety of industries
mostly across the tech media and
journalism industries as well as on a
personal project with my really great
friend Nadia Bremer where we chose
twelve different topics and created data
visualizations around those topics and
wrote about our whole process from start
to end so today I want to share with you
some of those past projects but more
importantly I want to share with you the
lessons that I learned throughout the
whole process of the data and design and
code so let's get started first the very
first thing of any data visualization
project is of course the data and I've
learned over the years that when I start
on a project for myself that I don't
actually
start with a particular data set and
instead what I do is I start out with a
curiosity because I found that as long
as I have a curiosity about something in
this world and that that curiosity will
motivate me throughout my project
especially when things get hard and as
long as I have that curiosity I found
that I can go and get very creative with
my data gathering process and find the
data sets I need to help satisfy and
answer that curiosity so in the summer
of 2016 I was extremely extremely
obsessed with this one musical called
Hamilton have heard it and even if you
have in raise your hand I can't see you
I'm sorry and but I was so obsessed I
had it on repeat for like three months
straight and my husband was like why
don't you just make like a data
visualization of it or something and I
was like no I mean that was like okay so
this is an interactive visualization of
every line in Hamilton where as I scroll
down the screen the dots kind of come
apart and bursts apart and come together
and each of these dots represent a set
of consecutive lines and that a
character sung in the musical and as I
keep scrolling down I present to the
reader the analysis that I did and the
interesting patterns and inch insights
that I found in the musicals until they
get to the very end where presents my
reader with the visual tool the filter
that I used to do my own analysis where
they can filter by any set of characters
conversations and themes and dig into
the remaining lines to do their own
analysis this project really started
because I had two primary questions two
primary curiosities the first being how
do the relationships
between these characters change as the
musical progresses and the second being
what recurring phrases what recurring
themes are there and who are they
associated with in the musical and as
you can probably imagine this there was
no such data set out there to help
satisfy this curiosity there's nowhere
on line that could have possibly found
it so I went and manually I manually
went through all of the lyrics the first
time around writing down and noting and
putting little like post-it notes on any
recurring phrases I found then once I
was done that I group them into broad
general themes and then I manually went
through the lyrics a second time so that
I can enter all of those recurring
phrases and themes into my computer
along with all of the characters and
conversations and then I advocated all
of that metadata by song and line number
I wrote a script to do this to get my
final dataset and this project and many
many others like this have really taught
me that as long as I have a curiosity
then I can really get any data set out
there whether it's by manual data entry
or with api's or automated scripts with
like no js' or I have friends that use
like our packages I'm there's as long as
you get creative there is some sort of a
data set out there as long as I stay
within the bounds of the law
yeah I don't want to do any illegal
things and so once once we have our data
um we want to then get on to our design
and one of the most important things I
learned is to really make sure to
explore our data that we just got before
starting on that design so this is one
of my favorite personal projects called
four years of vacations and 20,000
colors and it was one of my personal
project for data sketches where I took
four thousand images over thirteen
different personal trips and and
extracted the top five colors from each
of those images I grouped those colors
by the trip the trips that they were
taken on and I arranged them by the day
that they were taken on and this is one
of my favorite personal projects because
I feel like I learned about myself so
much from this project more than any
other project I've done um which is that
I've always known that when I travel I
really like taking pictures of nature
and so all of the blues and greens
really make a lot of sense and because I
like taking pictures of like mountains
and links and oceans and forests but
when I first did this project I was
really confused as to why I had all of
these reds and yellows and purples and
so when I took a look at the underlying
data set the underlying photos I learned
that uh there were all food pictures so
this 2014 trip to Japan apparently all
we did was eat one of my personal
favorite projects ah but when I actually
started on this project it actually
didn't start out that law what I mean by
this is this is one of my this is my
very first kind of sketch like a little
idea I drawed it down right after I had
gather and clean all of my data and I
had really good intentions which was
that I wanted to figure out
where and when I was taking my photos
and so you can see like I jot it down
this whole like weird like okay x-axis
is gonna be like the tenth time of day
and then also right by it it's gonna be
like the continents I took the pictures
in and the y-axis was gonna be and the
year that I took those pictures and it
just kind of sketched out some ideas
that I thought might be interesting the
problem was though that I hadn't I
hadn't taken a look at the data at all
after I gather they I didn't tried to
explore it I didn't try to understand it
and so what happened was uh so what
happened when I plugged the data into my
code I'm according to how I sketched it
out um yeah so I this is now one of my
favorite pieces I like to tell everyone
and it is a postmodern art piece and I
call it man King into puddle imagine
that one day something you know sell a
lot but I was like this is not a date of
his piece so I need to take a step back
so I took a step back and I really asked
myself what metadata do I have what
metadata does each photo each of my data
points have and I realized that I have
the trip that that photo was taken on so
I decided to group all of those colors
by that trip I have the information of
the day and time but that photo was
taken on and so I decided to map that to
the angle so that it would go around the
circle and finally because they are
colors I have huge saturation and
lightness information and so I decided
to map the hue to my radius so that it
would go in a gradient from orange to
yellow to green to blue to back to red
and that's how I got the final
visualization that you saw earlier and
so this project really taught me the
importance of exploring my data
where I start to ID in sketching
prototype and design and to really list
out my data attributes so that I can
assign the quantitative data attributes
like XY positions I'm sorry the
quantitative data attributes to the
right visual channels like XY positions
with height radius and the categorical
data attributes to visual channels like
color and shape and to make sure to
watch out for any extremes in the data
into account Frank outliers but over the
years I've also found that creating
compelling data visualizations take more
than just assigning the right data
attributes to the right visual channels
and I've know I've found that some of
the most some of the best visualizations
I've seen have a masterful use of visual
metaphors like when the New York Times
decided to visualize upward social
mobility literally as dots animating up
the screen or the any number of articles
that have decided to use a red bar
stripping down to signify a data set
about debts or murders and I firmly
believe that it is the subtle use of
visual metaphors that help our readers
kind of clue into what the underlying
data sight might be and reduce the
barrier of entry to understanding for
them when they come across a new exotic
visualization and in the world where our
users our readers are constantly
constantly constantly bombarded by
thousands of different things vying for
their attention on their screen I found
that it's important to design to
maximize for their delight to give them
little things little attentions to
detail little flashy details even that
will motivate them to keep engaging with
the story and to keep scrolling
the story this is a project I worked on
in fall 2017 with my really great friend
Nadia Bremer as well as the Guardian US
team called bust out and it was an
article about the homeless relocation
programs across American cities and to
do this project the Guardian us team
took a year and a half to get data from
16 different American cities and they
were able to obtain more than 20,000
data points of homeless people's
journeys across the u.s. there was a
really incredible piece of investigative
journalism where they looked into the
different cities and the bus tickets
that they were buying as well as the
plane tickets and their starting and
ending destinations for these people the
different income levels for each of the
cities that this was happening in and
even the acquaintances and the friends
and family that received the homeless
people on the other side as well as
potential motivations for this program
like how in San Francisco over the
course of 10 years more than 10,000
people have received bus tickets to go
to another city and that without this
program San Francisco would be double
the population so 90 and I worked on
five different visualizations for this
piece but today I want to concentrate on
just one of them and it's the one for
New York New York was a very unique city
in that it's the only American city that
not only bought bus tickets for their
homeless people but also plane tickets
and so I'm really turn on lists we
wanted to do two specific things first
to highlight the furthest flights
New York had bought for their homeless
and second to show the most frequent
destinations for their homeless people
so to accomplish the very first goal of
highlighting the furthest flight the
very first thing we thought of was a map
but we didn't want to use a map not only
because we had just used a map to start
and introduce the project and the data
set at the very beginning of the article
but we don't want to use a map because
maps are inherently just really bad by
comparing relative distances between
different starting and ending places
ending points and so the second thought
is a bar chart because our charts are
made for comparing relative differences
between different quantitative values
but we wanted to give our readers
something a little bit more visually
engaging and so what we and we came up
with this visual metaphor of a flight
taking off from one end of the screen
and flying across the screen in an arc
and landing on the other side and it was
really straightforward from there
to expand the visual metaphor to account
also for a second goal of showing the
most frequent destinations because we
could then show people as dots that
followed the flights across the screen
but even then it took many many many
iterations this just mean a few of them
to get the animation to a satisfying
point where we felt like it would engage
the reader and motivate them to keep
scrolling through the story without
really bogging them down in too much
animation and so this is the final
visual for New York where each arc is a
flight taking off and landing at their
destination and each dot increases as
more and more people arrive there
so so far we've talked a lot about the
data and the design but now I want to
talk about the code which i think is
what we're all really good at so to draw
data visualizations to create data
visualizations in the web and we need to
be able to draw shapes to the browser
and I like to joke around that data vis
is basically just SVG and trigonometry I
thought that's all that is but it's a
little bit true and one of the best
things that I think I've I did for
myself is to teach myself SVG path and
in particular all of the curve commands
that SVG paths have because with that
down with that understanding down I
found that I can really really dream up
and draw any shape that I want in the
browser so this is a project called film
flowers where I take the top summer
blockbusters of last two-and-a-half
decades and reimagine them as flowers
where each of the different petals are
parental guidence ratings each of the
colors are different genres and the
number and size of the petals are I am
DB ratings out of 10 and so there's some
I think really beautiful ones in here
like The Dark Knight Rises or in Section
I'm I always really like Harry Potter
that's just my favorite series and but
the one that I always always share that
I love sharing is the nineteen nineties
to have him back in and Robin
sorry but when I first published this
product I got asked um how could I do it
like how hard was it how much time did
it take um and the answer was that it
actually isn't as complicated as it
looks
I'm and what it's relying on is SVG
paths and especially specifically the
cubic Bezier curve command okay so let's
go through it together
so I want to draw a bat cherry blossom
shape and to do that I start out with a
curve on one side and so the way that I
like to think about it is that set and
that uh that a string I like to think of
it as I start out with a starting point
of zero zero I draw a straight line down
to my ending point that purple point I
then take a right and then take the blue
and green anchor points and I notch them
out until I get the point that I want
and that's the cubic Bezier curve
command I then draw two straight lines
draw the same curve but on the other end
and copy that petal basically an SVG
path I make that SVG path six more times
I transform and rotate them add in some
color and so that's how the flowers were
made but just drawing shapes onto a web
page doesn't make for a data
visualization either and so for us to
make data visualizations we need some
way to be able to translate the raw data
or raw data into screen space and while
I think that uh and and to do that we
need JavaScript libraries to help us and
why do I think that d3 is the
javascript library for creating data
visualizations on the web I actually
think that there are subsets of d3 where
other JavaScript libraries do a better
job and for the last few years I've
experimented with backbone and react and
view and my current absolute favorite is
using d3 with view and green sock for
more efficient coding and I want to show
you and hopefully convince you of that
with this demo visualization I have it
is a visualization of the blockbusters
of the top ten blockbusters of the last
ten years and there's two parts to this
visualization first is this these two
histograms at the bottom that show the
distribution of meta scores and box
office figures and the second part is
this kind of like quote custom part up
above I'm just like calling an area Troy
because I don't know what to call it um
but each of these little curves little
areas represent a movie and they rise
above the baseline when they're
box-office figure is above the median
box office and they droop below the
baseline when they make a box-office
figure that's below the median and
inflation adjusting and I have an
additional interaction where I can brush
over these histograms and filter all of
the visualizations with it so if for
example I want to look at any movies
that didn't do so well in the box office
but dude scored really well then that's
Molly
it's the lego movie the Martian and
conversely if I want to see which movies
did better than the median but weren't
such great movies then that's
transformers
transformers in Suicide Squad so today I
want to code this visualization with you
and this is this is where I start doing
the like live code portion of my talk so
please
it's probably the last time I'm gonna do
this cuz uh it just is really too
nerve-wracking anyways so we're gonna
start with this um I already have the
histogram built out just for the sake of
time and we're going to make the area
chart together and so this is my code
and I have an app top view that's my
root component and in here I load my
data and then I register that data with
you telling it that I want to keep track
of changes with it and then I have an
area chart component and the histogram
component where I pass in that movies
data set and within the area chart
component I receive the movies data set
as a prop from up top view and I tell
view that I want to watch for any
changes on that movies data set and if
there are changes then I want to
calculate the scales and I want to
calculate the data and what I mean by
calculating the scales is that in d3 we
use a series of different scales to
translate our raw data into what we need
on the screen so for example I decided
that for my visualization that I want to
map my release dates to the x-axis so
let's do that together first thing I
need to do is go and get the minimum and
maximum release dates and so I tell d3
but I have my data set and give me back
the min and Max for the release date and
then I create an X scale and I use a d3
scale time and what that does is it
takes in as input a JavaScript date
object and
it has an output that is a continuous
numerical value and so what I want to do
is I want to have as input two months
before the minimum release date and two
months after haha thank you for the live
debugging oh I love I love when that
happens thank you so much
and then I want to map the minimum date
to the left left side of my
visualization and the maximum date to my
right side and so what I'm gonna do then
is I have a margin object defined up top
and when the same margin left and then
I'm gonna say the width of my
visualization minus margin dot right so
my min date to my left and my max date
to my right and then I want to map my
box-office figure to my y-axis but I
want to also have a baseline that's the
medium box-office figure so I'm going to
use d3 to give me the median for the
movie for the movies and then I'm gonna
go and calculate again minimum
box-office and maximum box-office
actually let me have minimum and maximum
box-office pass in my data set and tell
it the box-office figure for that movie
subtracted by the median box-office and
then I want to have a y scale using d3
scale linear and scale linear what it
does is it has as input a continuous
numerical value and as up
also a continuous numerical value so I'm
passing in them in the mag's box and
then I tell it that I want to map my
minimum value to the bottom of my
visualization so that would be the
height of the visualization - a little
bit of margin and the maximum box office
figure to the top of my visualization so
a little bit of margin there and then I
also want to remember the Y position of
my baseline my medium box office figure
and then one more mapping so I want to
map my meta scores to some colors and so
I have a nice score extent some movies
and then I'm gonna use D score and the
color scale is do you three dot scale
sequential which just means that it's a
continuous input and a I'm sort of like
a continuous but an interpolator and I'm
going to use pass in as the output and
interpolate it or call interpolate
Verdi's that's just kind of like a color
scale and pass in as domain my min max
score and finally with d3 I'm going to
create an area generator with d3 area
and what d3 area does is that if we pass
it an array of points d3 will draw a
line a straight line through all of the
points and then fill everything the area
underneath it until the baseline and
then I want to tell it instead of
defaulting to a straight line I just
want to default it to this other kind of
like more wrong curve and then I'm gonna
tell it the baseline but I want which is
the Y position of the median box office
and so now we have all the set of 43
this was the most complicated part and
then I'm gonna say that I want to create
I'm an arc for each movie
and so let me remember first let me just
give it an ID and then for the SVG path
string I'm going to use that area
generator that I just created and
because the area generator takes in the
array of points the three points that we
want to draw that curve is starting at
the baseline
two months before the release date going
up to the release date and the
box-office figure and back down to the
baseline two months after the release
day and let's do that together so the
exposition of two months before the
release date and the baseline then the
exposition of the release date as well
as the Y position of the box office
figure - the median box and then I'm
just gonna copy this one bag so that
it's two months after I'm gonna do the
color color scale and then pass in the
score if I've done this correctly oh
thank you so much you are like one of
the most helpful audiences I've had
you're amazing thank you for like the
live debugging good looking out what's
your hourly rate I'm yeah so hopefully
now with the live debugging I'm I've
that it's gonna hopefully work and so if
they've done that cool okay so I have 98
movies and for each movie I have the
color in this incredibly long SVG path
string and this is IO all of this
working on the first try to your life
debugging thank you um and so now what
we have to do is render it and this is
the thing I
love about view so I'm gonna just say
create an SVG path for each arc data
that we just made and then for the key
I'm gonna use the data id and for the
path string I'm gonna do the path that I
just that path string that we just
created together I'm gonna fill it with
the color and Stroke it with just some
white so that we can see them
overlapping and the reason why I love
using d3 with view is that you saw all
of that like you know long d3 chain of
things and with this one line of view it
replaces like dozens of lines and d3
that does exactly the same thing and so
this just I just feel I just love it
because it makes me so much more
efficient so with just this one line
passing in the data that we that we
prepped there we go and now what I want
to do with you
is coat that interaction that I showed
earlier the brushing interaction that
maybe looks like it might be a really
complex but I want to show you that with
d3 and with the view it's not as complex
as it looks
I'm and so let's get started let's now
go into my histogram component and here
I have this kind of black box
SVG group elements I given a rough and
amount I've created a instance of a d3
brush and I just use d3 and select that
group element I'm sorry brush element a
group element with a rough brush and
call that d3 brush instance and in these
few lines what degree has gone and done
for us is create the Dom elements we
need an interaction we need to have that
brush and that drag interaction and I
love this also but you might notice that
like none of the filtering is happening
because we haven't hooked all of it up
yeah and to do that what we want to do
is on the brush instance I have these
two functions that are called while the
brush dragging is happening and on the
end of the brush and drying and so down
here I've defined it and what I want to
do is go and see if d3 dot selection
exists and what that is is the this
gives us the expositions of the left and
right bounds of this brush so then not
what we can do is define our bounds as
the X scale but I have invert pass in
the x position and what this does is
that with d3 scale not only can I go
from the input to the output so from the
raw data to the screen space I can also
do umber and go from my x position back
to my raw data and so and then I want to
pass the bounce back up to my route ab
component so I'm gonna just tell it the
histogram and pass in the bounds and I'm
gonna go back up to add up view where I
have my update filters method and just
make sure that I'm passing up the right
thing
the console.log this and so now yes okay
so now I'm I have that I just brushed
over a Metascore between 48 and cemani
and I can be like this and I've brushed
over a box office from these numbers and
now what I got to do is I'm just gonna
go and remember that filter
and then I'm going to filter my original
movies data set such that the only ones
that are kept the only movies that are
attempt are the ones that fit within the
bounds of those filters and so let's ski
this is the part I always get really
nervous about then
okay so I have my bounds and my filter
and I want to make sure that either
there is no nothing being filtered or
that they that that value falls within
the bounds and console dot log this
stuff filtered and so if I've done this
correctly then I'm when I filter things
then the original data set is 98 but I
should see it as less so yeah I have 45
so many 6 movies etc and you can also
tell that it's working because I'm this
histogram is already hooked up and it's
happening um and I just want to go and
hook this area chart up and to do that
I'm I'm passing down the filtered data
set into my area chart and I'm gonna
tell area chart to also look for changes
to watch for changes in the filtered
data set and every time there's changes
just go and recalculate the data
recalculate the arcs that I'm drawing
and down and calculate data instead of
making an arc for every movie I'm gonna
make an arc for every filtered movie and
now
and one last tiny little detail to
finish up I'm as you might notice like
all of these arcs are just like jumping
in and maybe we want like a nice
animation to smooth it out and make it
feel better make it feel more delightful
um and the other thing I love about view
is that um animation is a first-class
citizen so it has great integration with
green saw and all I have to do to make
that happen is put is to have these
transition groups and put my SVG paths
my arcs in the transition groups and it
calls these enter and leave functions
when the arcs need to be in to be
animating in or out and down here I have
these two functions and I use green
socks between light to say when a arc is
supposed to enter just have it scale up
and then when an arc needs to leave the
Dom just have it scale down these three
things now they just nicely hate me
which makes me very very happy
so thank you so I use the way I like to
think about it is that I use d3 mmm and
I use the d3 modules for scales and
shapes to translate my raw data into the
screen space that I need and I also use
modules like axes and brushes for to
implement very common data visualization
patterns I think d3 does these better
than any other library out there but I
also like to use view for their
reactivity system to replace D threes
enter update exit pattern and also their
dispatch system and finally I like to
use green sock and in particular tween
with view to replace D threes transition
D threes animation module and green sock
timeline for any more complicated
multi-step animations I might do and all
of this together have at least for me
resulting in fewer lines of code and
much faster development
so if there's anything that you liked in
what you saw or any part of this talk I
have a few more talks I expands on
subsets of my talk like talks about
reactant III and I also have some front
and workshop front and master's
workshops that cover intro to d3 and
goes more into detail about the data and
design process of building custom data
visualization so if you are interested
and I hope you are because that's what
I'm doing that's why I do this but I
hope you are and if you are then um
please check out any of these talks and
workshops and that make me very happy
thank you so much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]